what's up it's your Girl Slime around
here one and not only you can catch me
on bootleg kev's podcast
it's the bootleg cat show special guest
representing Memphis is this correct
correct slimeroni the one and only
can we figure out how we got to
salimarroni is the rap name where did we
how do we land here yeah so slime my
homies gave me their name and then Roni
is short for Tenderoni so you're are you
anyone's Tenderoni currently no no no no
no no no I figured like maybe you're
really into macaroni passionately about
that or oh yeah I got a song called
macaroni but I'm I'm the macaroni you
see what I'm saying I don't feel what
you're saying elaborate
being a Mac is like I got the juice I
got you got the juice you know do you
know how to make macaroni yeah like is
it good though yeah
give me your recipe how do we we got the
metal we got the metal tray okay how
many layers of cheese what are we doing
do five layer cheese okay got some
butter got the noodles eat the milk yeah
what else you need in there like
[__] I forgot
to activate this [__] but yeah yeah I
get what I'm saying so you you put your
Mac and Cheese against most people's
would you say I mean I don't know I
don't I don't think so I mean I could
cook but I ain't gonna say I'm just like
can I just hear you say music
wow
I thought you were about to hit me with
that music nah
I thought she was going straight to that
music
see Memphis got different sides so like
we all kind of talk different everybody
from every side that I've I've talked to
everyone's people who are Ops with each
other people everyone says music you're
the only person from Memphis that said
music
though I don't even say music anymore I
use the same music I do I love it yeah
I'm like kind of envious of your guys
was accent because I think it's amazing
thank you yeah shout out to Memphis it's
a great place
um obviously Memphis is on fire right
now you're doing this gorilla tour
um how has the tour been it's been cool
everybody being fun everything been
going smooth like Fast cool yeah would
you say like uh because this is your
first big tour this is my first tour
period yeah is there anything that
you've had to like kind of like learn on
the Fly you know like how important
socks might be or uh extra draws yeah
you just gotta go with the flow most of
the time like a lot of spontaneous still
be happening so you just gotta be ready
what's the most random [__] so far
I really don't know like we just be
going from place to place and doing
different [__] all the time like it's
hard to say rapping and [__] rapping you
know vibing you know what I'm saying so
what part of Memphis are you from I'm
from the East the East who else is from
the East for this two times okay so yeah
hey guys by the way one of my favorite
interviews I've done in a long time hey
way to go way to go over there uh
super nice guy well I mean he's he was
nice to me yeah yeah super nice to me is
he on your guys's label no he's not okay
shots of finesse great guy uh he dope is
here he's I love I love the way he raps
and he be he's like kind of like the new
age sugar-free or too short because he'd
just be rapping about pimping and
shooting and that [__] reminds me it
just reminds me of my childhood because
all my like when I was a kid I loved you
know two shortest yeah
so too short
his whole [__] was he's a pimp yeah same
thing with sugar-free you don't know who
that is though no yeah all my time you
got to get hip on that sugar-free okay
you know I mean so he's from the East
side anybody else not that I know okay
so finesse two times shout out to him
yeah who would you consider to be like
if we were to put together the Mountain
West almost at Mount Westmore you see um
brainwashed by Ice Cube 42 short and
Snoop Dogg the Mount Rushmore of Memphis
hip-hop who's on the who's on the was it
four people four see look I'm [__] up
well I'm a guy hits that Gangster Boo
cause that's my girl rest in peace
Legend you know what I'm saying and
I would say
damn
two people who aren't with us anymore
that's something to think of this looks
who else who is
uh
project bag [__] yeah I was hoping
you're gonna okay I'm loving this so far
you're [__] on point yeah okay
and oh
trying to think who is from Memphis I
could say
[Music]
I don't know Juicy J I don't know Juicy
J that's a great four I like that yeah
would you say Obviously Gangsta Boo is
uh she was one of the nicer ladies that
I've met I had a couple of dope
encounters with her uh big loss in
hip-hop she obviously I think probably
doesn't get enough respect in terms of
like when we talk about like all-time
great female rappers like what was your
relationship like with her man she was
really supportive of everything that we
did like always commenting like shaking
in with us and stuff and like she's
always encouraging us and remind us how
dope we are and stuff so really like
when we start popping out this one Falls
really start going back and paying
attention so like I agree she really
didn't in my opinion fully get her
flowers while she was here she was just
still feel like she was just still
warming up you know what I'm saying I
think she was gonna come hard this year
what was uh for you like growing I mean
obviously you mentioned a lot of the
hypnotized mind [__] like that's a kind
of a generation before you yeah where I
mean that says a lot about their reach
in terms of just like
their influence and the music was
incredible but like how big of a fan of
the hypnotized mind [__] were you
growing up or was it kind of like before
your time yeah that was before my time
and like I grew a beautiful I grew up
Catholics I like it was a lot of gospel
music and my mom like they have Catholic
Gospel music no
I mean I don't think I like gospel music
I didn't have never heard a Catholic
Gospel music I mean like the church I
don't know it's real like quite a lot of
prayers stand up send down but it's like
all black churches South Memphis right
like that's a cat it's a Catholic Church
yeah but the choir we get down though
July any other Baptist right all that
other stuff so you grew up in the church
pretty conservative
yeah my folks are streaked on me yeah
what do they feel about you being like a
rapper now and doing your thing when my
stepdad he always worrying all the time
like just be safe and watch out for
strangers don't do this don't do that
but my mom she real cool and support
right how old are you 25. okay so you're
you're not like that you you've lived
some life yeah I got it got some season
on me um how long have you been rapping
for like five six years five or six
years yeah at what point in time did you
feel like there was like a breaking
point where you realize that you could
really take it serious and like you know
maybe make some money
uh probably around like 2018 I'll say
like
stuff just started progressing for me
like me different producers and they're
working all this stuff so once I really
started seeing
results from what I was doing that's
when I was like okay this could really
take out for me what's it like working
with the hit kid guy because he's got
you know he's he's a guy hey he he's Joe
Jackson which I don't know he's he's fun
but he crazy like when he's trying to
work his sign to work Joe Jackson is
Michael Jackson's dad yeah so probably
not a great comparison
Charlie
I mean he was [__] them kids yeah but
nah he really be like hard on us and
stuff but like in a good way like we're
in the studio he'll be like I know y'all
could do better than that and like let's
stop playing around let's get this done
right but when it's time to play it'd be
time to play that's fair hey we got to
interrupt the interview man hey shout
out to my bookie man make sure you go to
mybookie.ag NFL season it's over but it
might bookie the opportunities to win
they're not over baby they don't stop
ever all right whether you want to make
some extra or just make the games more
exciting my book is going to give you
the most for your money with their
deposit bonuses now listen if you sign
up right now go to mybookie.ag use that
promo code bootleg you're gonna get a
welcome bonus up to a thousand dollars
and on top of that March Madness is on
the way ladies and gentlemen that's
right that college basketball tournament
is coming they're gonna give you a free
150 000 March Madness bracket contest
entry imagine if you win 150 Grand you
have to put no money up crazy you got to
go to mybookie.ag sign up with that
promo code bootleg right now thousand
dollar deposit bonus if you put a
thousand and they gonna give you another
thousand all right and of course so much
to bet on what my book you could do NCAA
NBA NHL UFC boxing what J is Jake Paul
gonna win I don't know but you could you
could put some money on Jake Paul I
would all right of course they also got
their weekly online Blackjack
tournaments so much roulette I mean
slots so much with so many Brands to
choose from trust my bookie I've been
rocking with them for over 10 years God
damn it and they're so easy to get your
money out of so easy to make money with
they got the best like simplest platform
to use the best props man trust me bet
anything anytime anywhere
with my bookie mybookie.ag promo code
bootleg sign up also shout out to our
family at hardean Jardine Las Vegas Yes
you see him
I was just there in Vegas yesterday this
is the best place I've ever been to in
terms of dispensaries I've been to
probably hundreds of these things and
the experience at hardean is like
nowhere else
the customer service the selection of
Premium cannabis the experience as a
customer that you get when you walk into
the building in Las Vegas is a bar none
the best it's just the best man they are
the best we got so much going on this
weekend they're sponsoring the Rolling
Stone party on Friday Super Bowl weekend
fabulous Thursday offset Friday Meek
Saturday it's a lot going on with
Jardine you got to follow him at hardean
underscore Las Vegas right now shoot
them a follow on Instagram while you're
at it go to their website
hardinglasvegas.com so much fly gear so
much fly weed what are we talking about
baby shout out to hardine man that's the
family man go if you're in Vegas pull up
on them man Jardine Las Vegas
um for you do you remember the last real
job you had
I think I worked at Amazon
how long were you there how long was
Jeff Bezos uh underpaying you oh God
right like three five months
what's the longest gig you had prior to
being a rapper because that's not very
long three or four months yeah
probably like six
six seven months where was that at
I was a Hollister
you were selling Hollister jeans yeah
holy White Boy [__]
they recruited me actually crazy is when
I was like in high school like we used
to like there was like Hollister and
Abercrombie and we used to like [__]
hate the kids
see I went to school with the white kids
so that's what that start like with the
whites yeah with the whites like in high
school it's still like that's why I
started going to school so you you went
to school with the whites yeah
[Laughter]
I mean you know what I'm trying to say I
mean you worked at [__] Hollister
there's not a wider place to work
there just isn't
what's the Pro Bass Shop a lot less
white than Hollister
um it's like country like I mean yeah
there's probably some rednecks over
there in Tennessee definitely yeah
there's a lot of
what what kind of Dwight's were you with
if they weren't redneck what kind were
they that was I just want to get into
the classification of caucasians here
let's break it down
that was kind of like the hippies like
they smoked weed like nice I really give
a [__] about school they always chilling
and stuff so you were there with my
cousin real artsy
did they did they did you do mushrooms
with these kids I didn't start doing
mushrooms like a couple years ago but I
did smoke with them nice yeah so you
were like this is like a white high
school it went like it was a lot like it
was white it was a lot of black people
tools a lot of like
Asian people there too so shout out
today I didn't know there was ages I
thought we just had them in Cali and in
New York yeah certain parts yeah like a
lot of Indians
so yeah which kind of Indians though
the ones from Asia I'm from Arizona and
so all of my friends who are native
American they're like Navajo yeah and
then there's Indians yeah from India
yeah yeah yeah
gotta specify yeah you know what I mean
Indian food is great have you had it I
haven't you gotta have some Indian food
would you recommend uh what's it Curry
we had a curry yeah that's really all I
had it's amazing it's like the most
basic [__] [__] you could say yeah okay
it'd be like if somebody said you should
try American food and they'd be like
yeah have a cheeseburger okay yeah no
[__] yeah that's all I had uh what do
you got going on right now musically
obviously you're on tour you got your
you got records out but like what's
coming up next I'm about to drop a
single mm-hmm dropping it on the 17th so
I'm excited about that I have a project
coming and like different features
throughout the year a whole bunch of
stuff
uh for you uh when you put a project
together
how do you decide like what makes the
I'm sure you're gonna have a bunch of
songs to choose from yeah how do you
decide what makes the album it's just
really the vibe that I'm adding life at
that moment because it's like
the way I'm me doing music I've had like
different areas where I do different
stuff so like wherever I'm at mentally
physically out at this where I go which
areas
have you been in so far
um I was in my real cocky area in the
beginning just like I'm the [__] I could
rap like you know what I'm saying
thinking like I gotta work hard I'm cute
I could do all that everything I'm like
no [__] like hard work beats handling
every time so of course then I started
getting my mature start being more like
technical my lyrics and stuff like they
really start like pushing myself more
and then I got to where I got into my
emotions like letting people see
different sizes ain't vulnerable yeah
that's important yeah because that's
what people relate to mm-hmm but you
could catch like a [__] hit and then
if people don't feel like you know
that's why I think what happened with
glow was like she started doing
interviews people were like oh this
she's amazing yeah I just like her yeah
I'm cool as [__] yeah she's super cool
yeah yeah what's it like touring with
her is it like a Vibe like yeah she's a
fun time yeah like everybody always is
high positive energy she loves that wine
teleport wine it gets you [__] up she
she did my club in Arizona and they put
that on the rider and I'm like guys I
don't know where to [__] get this
[__] 11 o'clock at night
I know it's like 6.99 a bottle it's not
the product I'll give you guys 10
bottles of the show yeah
that's the job right there are you a
Teleport fan I am okay I am that's a
Memphis [__] or not
I don't know I feel like there's some
glow [__] she really put me on she put
you under the wine yeah the wine is a
Vibe yeah sometimes yeah it's heavy yeah
what's the worst mushroom chip you've
ever been on
um
I think I was like downtown in Memphis
it was like during like a hot wing
Festival some [__] [__] and I micro dose
and it was just so many people you know
like all the senses [__] started going
on I was like [__] I'm freaking out off
of micro dose yeah yeah it's tough if
you get like if you do shrooms at like a
concert and if it hit you the wrong way
it could be overwhelming for sure
at a hot wing Fest in Memphis that
sounds amazing
if I wasn't that highlight yeah it
probably would have been dope
so you pay for the general admission to
go to the hot wing Fest do you get a
wing from everybody how does this work
do you try Wings is it like is it like
I've been to Taco Fest and like every
tent's got a different Taco you gotta
try it like you could is this same thing
with the Hot Wheels yeah nice yeah
Memphis Barbecue better than anywhere
else period thanks I haven't had it you
should try I've only done Texas I mean
I've you know I've had places that say
it's Memphis style but I've never had
like I've never been to Memphis Can't
Nobody Do Memphis style better than
Memphis I agree
are you like uh obviously uh
the Grizzlies are going crazy right now
John morant's doing his his best to be
the next king Von you think so I don't
know I heard this story where John
Moran's homies was in a car shooting
late do you see that shooting lasers at
Pacers the Pacers
I think John Morant wants to put out a
drill album for sure because he is
moving around like
he's from oh block
are you like like are you like a
basketball fan are you hip with any of
the players or how familiar with it but
I don't watch basketball like right
right right right because then you got
like a guy like you know Zach Randolph
who's pretty was pretty intertwined into
the uh hip-hop scene out there yeah for
sure uh if you had to describe your top
two or three influences for you as a
rapper like how you rap lyrically what
you're trying to do who would it be
the top three I would say Lil Wayne
Eminem and Missy Elliott
who's that
or that it might have just been the wind
oh go see who that is Rock Lil Wayne
Eminem
and Missy yeah see you was listening to
that Eminem Show when you were selling
them Hollister pants
for sure what
why not what's your favorite Eminem
album
favorite song essays
dang what is it
and when I'm gone just carry on don't
more Rejoice every time I like this song
check you out yeah I know my stuff it's
Eminem huh I didn't see that coming yeah
shout out to Wayne
oh TK that big [__] it's all good all
right well look uh new single coming out
the 17th um is the 17th Michael Jordan's
birthday easy
that's Michael Jordan's birthday
yeah hey we got to stop the interview to
tell you about our good Folks at Blue
chew baby that's right A lot of people
keep asking me does Bluetooth work [__]
yeah it does and if you don't believe me
they'll give you a whole month for free
right now if you go to bluetooth.com and
use that promo code bootleg that's
bootry.com promo code bootleg you get a
month of blue chew for free delivered to
your [__] house all you do is pay
five dollars in shipping what is blue
tree you ask well let me tell you it has
the same active ingredient as Viagra and
Cialis in a chewable tablet but it is
discreetly delivered right to your
doorstep no awkward doctor's visits
imagine going and telling uh an old guy
about your dick
you would prefer not to do that I know
I'd prefer not to do that you know but
you can do it all online bluetooth.com
you don't have to go to the doctor's
appointment in person no more no they're
going to send it straight to your door
all right your wife won't even know it
came your wife won't know
that you came and it came all right so
what you do is
you uh you go to bluetooth.com use the
promo code bootleg and you get a month
of uh the whole thing for free that's
right a month supply of Bluetooth for
free straight to your door they also
just drop their new mint chewable which
is the same exact active ingredient as
Levitra so many options for you at
Bluetooth to make sure your dick is
right going into the springtime baby
look spring break's coming uh are you
gonna be coming
the real question is
is your partner going to be coming
not with the noodle dick
let's be honest make sure that shit's
hard as [__]
go to bluetooth.com use the promo code
bootleg and get a month supply for free
and if you're dealing with erectile
dysfunction it's okay man
it happens to the best of us go to
Bluetooth and put a Band-Aid on that
thing bluetooth.com promo code bootleg
also
while we're talking about our partners
shout out to our family at Odd Socks oh
look at these Odd Socks underwear man
they're they're Half Baked
so much going on at Odd Socks uh so many
dope licenses man shout out to uh they
got Cheetos they got Jaws [__] Oreos
Cheech and Chong Naruto WWE by the way
WrestleMania is coming I can't wait to
see what dope WrestleMania socks they do
this year because last year they knocked
it out the park at Odd Socks look the
most comfortable socks in the world they
got the odd Sox Basics that you need on
your feet uh all you gotta do is go to
oddsocksofficial.com right now use the
promo code bootleg at checkout you'll
save 20 off your total order underwear
socks
[__] hats whatever you need they got it
at Odd Socks uh they just got the
Coca-Cola deal so you go get some
Coca-Cola draws Coca-Cola socks so much
always going on in Odd Socks I'm gonna
always say my favorites are the WWE in
the Breaking Bad Ones
um so go to oddsoxofficial.com right now
use that promo code bootleg and you will
save 20 off at checkout shout out to
them most comfortable socks in the world
crazy comfortable underwear my goodness
if you ain't got Odd Socks on your feet
and ass what are you doing out in these
streets all right go to
hotsoxofficial.com promo code bootleg
save 20 off let's get back to the
interview very strange that I know that
but shout out to your MJ fan all right I
mean he's up there with Kobe even though
I do think that he's the actual goat
that's what I have a LeBron James toy
I'm a grown man with toys now I got some
just a little anime toys at home oh you
are you in the anime
yeah
what's your like like what's your if you
had to you know what are you watching on
the old what's that [__] called
Crunchyroll the [__] anime thing wait
what's your animes I'll be watching on
Hulu but I like Attack on Titan okay
with no assassination classroom oh
you're you're tapped in yeah my son says
Attack on Titan I think he says is the
best it is it's a really dope storyline
you don't do the Naruto or the uh yeah
Dragon Ball yeah yeah the first I ain't
got like the first Dragon Balls kind of
you want to know which anime I've seen
The Boondocks oh yeah this anime and
this is funny and there is a did some
[__] called Afro Samurai I watched that
this should be fat too those are the
only ones I've watched yeah I like those
is there any other animes that's about
it Boondocks is anime they try to not
count it as one because they're racist
but it is yeah it's definitely anime
yeah shout out to uh what about Pokemon
yeah when I was young I liked it you
ever get Pokemon cards yeah I did I was
whooping the existing Pokemon Andy
Yu-Gi-Oh cards Yu-Gi-Oh yeah [__] hey
man I feel like such a nurse by the way
that's okay yeah it's okay to be a nerd
listen we gotta let the people know yeah
a lot of people like anime I'm not one
of them I like the wire you know you
ever watch The Wire
heard of y'all never watched it I
watched it like once every two years it
was a long like HBO or something it is
okay it's about Baltimore and heroin and
there's this guy named Omar little he's
gay but he's like the craziest
[__] alive he'd be robbing all
the drug dealers and [__] little
Puerto Rican dudes in the ass oh my God
it's [__] crazy it's true though
it's based on the true story no no no
but it's it's pretty cool oh no it is it
is actually a lot of it is like yeah
because the guy who wrote it is from
Baltimore so he kind of wanted to tell
you should watch it yeah outside of
anime what's your favorite TV series
love the office
is a very good show to fall asleep to it
is you just throw that [__] on it hit
the hit the sheets and you got Steve
Carell in the background I love the
theme song it's a great theme song you
ever watch uh Curb Your Enthusiasm you
gotta watch that HBO just get the HBO
Max [__] account turn up curb in The
Wire all right all right well listen new
single coming what's the name of the
song rock star rock star I like that
thanks did you ever hear Rock Star by
Nickelback when you were working at
Hollister no I did
no you did you had to have heard
it one time but I don't remember
just love the Hollister thing
and I gotta let it go which is great
it's amazing did you get like do you
still have any of the jeans
no no you know what I got like I still
got some of the sweatpants and stuff
[__] right I introduced all the holy
jeans when I was a kid it was like why
is all these [__] rich white kids
wearing jeans with holes in them what
does these were high as [__] I could
barely afford those jeans they were too
much yeah yeah yeah well [__] Hollister
[Laughter]
yeah we're gonna have a freestyle
another YouTube video go watch that [__]